chair then I want to notice something
about opposition parties
they never indicate
note never will cooperate on proposals
that are done
by the PVV or 1 cabinet in which the PVV is located
I think it's outrageous
I will tell you honestly
because also with us
you could soon form 1 cabinet
and also at the PVV it does not have to agree with everything
I understand that very well
there will be good proposals in the field
from social domain
in the field of education
in the field of older care
and here is 1 party in the room that said
we will not cooperate with that
and those people
voted for this party
in the expectation that they will cooperate there
so I ask this party
just left p
from the a to reconsider this
that's bad for the country
what you are doing here